take it away
hi everyone um
thank you for the organizers it's great
to have an in-person conference and uh
thanks for the invitation to speak so
i'm gonna talk about some joint work
with uh gerard benarus and oprah
on
stochastic radiant descent and uh first
order methods for kind of simple
problems of parameter estimation in high
dimensions
so
the general framework that we're going
to be thinking about is
so you have a family of probability
distributions p sub theta and theta is
in r n so my parameter space is n
dimensional and n is large
and um
i'm going to get m iid samples from p
sub theta naught so there's some like
hidden or true parameter theta naught
and i'm getting iid samples from that
and the estimation task is of course to
produce an estimator that attains let's
say one minus little of one correlation
with state and otter essentially
recovers theta
okay
so this is a pretty general framework
and some simple examples that fit into
it that we've heard people talking about
over the past couple days
are for instance um
the first one here is tensor pca so you
get some gaussian k tensor iid entries
and it's spiked by
some rank one perturbation so in this
case it's going to be exactly the the
hidden parameter is the vector that you
raised to the tensor power like k
and maybe there's some signal to noise
parameter here or that can be absorbed
into the number of samples
another situation that you might think
about is you have some kind of like a
single layer network or like a
teacher-student framework where you have
an activation function f
you're given a project so you get to
take projections with let's say gaussian
feature vectors of the hidden parameter
theta naught you run it through some
non-linear activation f and maybe
there's some additive noise
and so what you're seeing is here
what you're seeing are iid things like
this where the randomness is over both a
and epsilon
um another framework you can think about
is like a mixture of two gaussians let's
say so here eta is just a plus minus one
with probability half half let's say
and so you either get theta naught plus
some centered gaussian or minus theta
not plus some centered gaussian and
you're trying to recover this vector
data
okay so
general framework and
what we're aiming to um understand is
let's say algorithmic thresholds using
some kind of first order method so a
general approach to these kinds of
problems is to
have some kind of a loss function let's
say a mean squared error or a log
likelihood or something
and
the best estimator given such a loss
function for generalization with for
instance is to take the minimizer of the
expectation of the loss where the
expectation is over the y
so
you want to have some algorithmic method
for outputting this x
and
a common algorithmic approach is to
minimize the empirical risk so you take
this running average over your losses
for the miid
data points that you got
and this ends up being so this is a
fairly high demand this is a function in
rn and oftentimes it can be pretty
complex in the sense that it has lots of
minima maybe exponentially many in the
dimension in the ambient dimension and
so optimizing this is a highly
non-convex problem
um
but it's something one could try and do
okay
using for instance a gradient descent or
a longivan dynamic something like
so
the goal for the talk or our goal
generally is for maybe simple problems
of
simple choices of this loss and simple
problems in a way that i'll explain
later understand the thresholds in terms
of the number of samples so the
the m necessary in terms of n
needed for first order methods to
uh obtain one minus little of one
correlation with the hidden vector theta
naught when initialized from random
initialization so sometimes spectral
initializations can help but i really
want to key in on the role that
initializing randomly and just using a
first order
approach
what does that do for us and
why is that different from when you use
something like a spectral initialization
so the kinds of things that i mean by
first order methods
well oh sorry before i get there
so there's two kind of well-studied
approaches to this uh this problem
um
for instance you think let's have in
mind gradient flow or longivan dynamics
on r which is the empirical risk so
one approach to getting thresholds for
this problem is mixing times
so for instance with the longivan type
of thing or an mcmc algorithm you can
understand how long does it take for the
algorithm to converge to its stationary
distribution from a worst case
initialization okay and there's a lot of
tools for this you can find some kind of
a bottleneck in the landscape
um
terminology like free energy wells and
overlap gap property that we've heard
over the last couple days come up and a
lot of people here have worked on things
like this and so
generally the approach is to show that
some observable of your system has some
kind of bottleneck so you have to
transition from some large mass region
to another large mass region through
some small mass region and for your
stationary distribution that's hard and
therefore from a worst case
initialization it takes exponentially
long generally for you to mix
okay
that's used as a
an indication of the hardness for
an mcmc approach for this so for
instance you can think of like jerem's
paper for a planted clique as such a
thing
but
there's not really an indication that
random initializations can't somehow
avoid these kinds of bottlenecks and
that's a general paradigm that i'm
interested in
another class of approaches does kind of
hone in on maybe different kinds of
initializations other than worst case
and that's based on
taking limiting odes fixed points of
limiting ods looking at state evolutions
things like that so
there's a
mean field limit amp state evolutions
generally these kinds of approaches
first send an n to infinity limit and
then take time large and so what that
means is these are short time
asymptotics so
the success or failure of local
algorithms you can say something about
it in order n many steps sometimes order
and log in using some kind of stability
arguments
but
not beyond that and so there's a gap
between so these these kinds of
approaches maybe you can say something
about if you started uh from a random
initialization or from like a nice
initialization that you're actually
interested in but the kind of uh
algorithmic obstruction you'd get is
that in
order one time or in order sorry order
one in continuous is an indiscreet so um
in short time you're not going to be
able to
get to a you know reasonable recovery
so there's a whole gap between
this kind of time scale or this kind of
number of steps and the exponential
kinds of things that you get from worst
case and so
what i want to talk about is um
answers to the following two types of
questions so
are there situations in which a random
initialization really gives you an
advantage over a worst-case
initialization kind of thing maybe the
these kinds of overlap gap properties
can even tell you in a worst case
initialization within a subset of your
space like where you have even it's
starting near zero correlation but still
it might be that a random initialization
does better than the worst point with
zero correlation
so that's the first question
and the second is
are intermediate time scales relevant
so is it possible that even though these
kind of fixed point approaches kind of
get stuck on order one times if you wait
a little longer like
a polynomial in n you actually are able
to do better so maybe there are problems
where
it's not either a short time or an
exponential kind of trade-off but
there's some polynomial threat that time
scale that's relevant
so with that i'll talk about so some of
the kinds of first order methods that
i'm thinking about generally
are
gradient descent where um you know your
update is just you take the gradient of
your empirical risk this n is to match
the order and first order one tradeoff i
was talking about earlier
and you have some step size delta
so you do this kind of just simple
gradient descent update another option
is a this longivan type dynamics where
you add some white noise uh step every
time
and maybe what i'll be talking about
most for this uh for the purposes of
this talk because it's the easiest to
analyze is a stochastic gradient descent
algorithm where instead of optimizing
this risk function you just you're get
you're getting this uh your data point
to y and you're just using a gradient
update with that single data point okay
so
all of these you can do a kind of simple
rewriting where you subtract off the
generalization error
and
so what you'll see is there's this
common part to all three of these
situations to all three of these um
algorithms that i'm talking about where
you just update with the generalization
error or the population loss
and then there's some mean zero
correction and this means your
correction in the online sagas gradient
descent situation is iid
in the other situations it's not iid but
at a fixed x it's mean zero
okay so
generally
you can think of in the small step size
limit you get cancellations from these
mean zero terms and so these algorithms
are going to be well approximated by
just a kind of dynamics that updates
using the mean of your loss function
okay
of course that's a small step size with
the dimension fixed and or with time
order one relative to the ambient
dimension and so while that
approximation gives you these kinds of
mean field limiting equations and that's
how you get like
n to infinity then time to infinity
limits
if you're trying to hone in on time
scales that diverge with the dimension
you need to actually care about this
perturbative term
okay so everything that i'm going to say
in the rest of the talk we're just going
to focus on online sgt in the case of
tensor pca and maybe some other simple
examples we can say some things about
gradient descent and launch event but
it's obviously easier to work with the
sgd situation okay
so
let's focus on this population dynamics
which is not true that
it's not true that i guess by mean field
uh approaches you refer to iterative
approaches like kmp is not true that you
replace that thing by zero in those
approaches
in amp there's an extra correction term
right yeah i mean but it's not
equivalent i mean you can analyze like
an ode limit kind of approach yeah
you're not replacing that you're not
taking the average
by zero of this approximation okay
you're not
i mean yeah it's like in the coriander
quartion you're not replacing that by
zero
but there are situations in which like
if i looked in a fixed dimension limit
then i if i looked in fixed dimension
and took a delta zero limit then i would
be doing that fixed dimension yes
so
in the population dynamics um
so let's let's view the
these systems as a perturbation of uh
just a population dynamics which is how
you'd view the system if you were in a
kind of fixed dimension setting or like
a low dimensional setting and then we'll
get to the role of the extra mean zero
term
so
if i look at this system where i'm just
updating according to this
generalization error what ends up
happening is in all of the examples i
described for instance or a lot of
parameter estimation problems that are
kind of simple in some sense you might
expect that the
function phi is low dimensional very
effectively even though the empirical
risk is a high dimensional function
that's very
complex okay
and so for instance
um we could assume that this function
phi is just a function of some notion of
your distance to the true parameter okay
the population really shouldn't care too
much about the other directions and
maybe you have a radial term if you're
working in full space so in a spherical
prior we'll take something like this and
with a gaussian prior in full space for
instance we could look at something like
a normalized inner product
okay
[Music]
so we're going to assume that our
function phi is effectively low
dimensional and in this case effectively
one dimensional for the purpose of the
talk
and
for instance in the spike tensor model
or the tensor pca problem which can we
can use as a kind of running example
um this phi is just of the form
essentially m minus m to the k uh with
some extra connection
so here's in matrix bca which is the
case k equals to 2 you have something
like this
and this x axis here is m
so the correlation going from minus 1 to
1 or the normalized correlation going
from -1 to 1.
on the right hand side you have tensor
pca for a three tensor let's say okay
um
and what you see is in these kinds of
problems
there's a saddle point at the
origin so exactly when you have zero
correlation you have a saddle point
which
maybe
is um
is gonna be an obstruction to recovery
because you can
realize that if you take a random
initialization you're going to typically
start with correlation that's
microscopic
okay
so
where as i said the fixed dimensional
intuition suggests that your stochastic
gradient descent is just a perturbation
of this dynamical system this dynamical
system gets stuck where you initialize
and like a short time asymptotics are
only relevant if you start kind of away
from the
origin
so
in order to make this more formal we
also have to assume something on the
size of the noise because if the noise
is too small then you're just ending up
with this uh population dynamics and if
the noise is too large then it might be
doing something uninformative okay
so our assumptions on the size of the
noise that we're going to be talking
about are that um
this normalized thing so by noise i mean
the loss minus its expectation
is well behaved in that it has like a
high dimensional scaling so it's
much it's projection in the direction of
this uh hidden parameter theta naught is
much smaller than its norm
so in this case
we're thinking about for instance the
projection in the direction of theta
naught being order one whereas the norm
of the gradient itself being order and
order root n typically
so
in particular a gaussian vector in r n
fits this scaling relation
okay so this is kind of a high
dimensional scaling where we're saying
that once you subtract off this mean
term
this is an uninformative landscape it's
not really it has no reason to point you
towards the true parameter anymore okay
and again this is a setting that's uh
satisfied by the kinds of problems i
mentioned earlier so for instance in
tensor pca your extra term is this
gaussian k tensor acting on x to the k
and in this case it really is like a
just a gaussian vector
in uh then one layer network with
gaussian features you can see that your
population is this kind of quantity
where these are the hermit coefficients
of your activation function
and once you subtract that off then
l minus phi satisfies the kind of
scaling relations i mentioned on the
earlier slide
and in the binary gaussian mixture model
again similar situation okay
so this framework at least satisfies
these kinds of one-dimensional recovery
problems where we're just caring about
the correlation with this
hidden signal
so
the kind of stochastic approximation or
limiting ode approach i was talking
about um where you just send this extra
mean zero term to zero
is valid
in the regime where you're starting away
from the
away from this saddle point at the
origin okay so if i start with any omega
one correlation
then i'm going to
then i'm going to move pretty quickly
with the population dynamics right
because it has some positive drift in
this case the right hand side in this
case away from the origin and as soon as
it has a positive drift i can do a kind
of standard argument to argue that i
have a law of large numbers so my
correlation to the truth
is within a little of one distance of
the correlation to the truth of this
like population dynamics this population
dynamics again is just
you're running uh you're just following
the dynamical system dictated by this
simple one-dimensional function okay so
this is saying the low-dimensional
intuition is really valid
okay
and based on this you end up with a
system where you have a fixed point at
the origin which is unstable for
instance and then an attractor at
correlation one
and in between these you have a lot of
large numbers even in this high
dimensional regime because you can
project down and nothing goes wrong
because things move quickly
but when you're near the saddle the
population dynamics is very slow
so
the
because um
because you're starting microscopically
close to the origin
so
this is the law of large numbers picture
if i start with some positive
correlation of one half you see these
are
repeated trajectories of stochastic
gradient descent they'll converge to the
same trajectory and that's given by the
ode that's given to you by the
population loss
but if you start really close to the
origin and again if i start with a
random like gaussian prior then its
correlation with a fixed vector is
little is one over root n typically so
i'm looking at a one over root n
neighborhood of the origin
then
the population dynamics is going to take
a diverging amount of time to escape
this small window and actually reach a
region where it moves quickly so even
though i have this kind of law of large
numbers on linear time scales
it's and it's not telling me anything
i'm just staying fixed and when i look
at this like correlation function
okay
so i need to go beyond these kinds of
short order one time scales
and so the
i want to kind of hone in on this
unstable fixed point and uh the behavior
there
how much time do i have
okay
um
so yeah so
in this regime where the population
dynamics is slowed down we need to kind
of avoid sending n to infinity first and
uh and then looking at short-time
asymptotics we have to hone in on the
trade-offs between these two things and
in order to do that
so yeah so the consequence here is that
if i draw x naught randomly then my
correlation starts close to a saddle of
phi
and in particular most of the data is
needed to be used so most of the data i
need is used already before i get to
this kind of law of large numbers regime
okay so if you want to really understand
the system you also have to understand
this first stage
and um the question i want to ask is how
much data is actually needed to escape
this instability this unstable saddle
point in the origin
so to hone in on that i'm going to
define what's what i'll call an
information exponent and it's a notion
of kind of
the
level of instability of the saddle point
okay so
i'm just going to say it's k if the
first non-zero derivative of this
function phi
at the origin is the k-th one okay
so if k is one
then there's not even a critical point
there it's not a saddle and truly just
the limiting ode that you get is the
truth you quickly descend to correlation
one so that's for instance the case with
this single layer network with an
activation function that's relu okay so
here you do quickly descend to the truth
in this simple problem because there's
no saddle point at your initialization
but suppose that we took like a f of x
that's the absolute value of x so
there's a phase retrieval kind of
problem
then
there is a saddle at the origin that's
separating a kind of sign symmetry in
the problem
and this slows the dynamics down
because when you initialize you're
starting really close to this fat flat
region
and so that we're going to call it k
equals to 2 because it's the second
derivative is non-zero okay
and you can have things for instance if
i take the third hermit coefficient as
my activation function which is a kind
of bizarre thing to do then i can have
things or a better example maybe as a
tensor pca with a three tensor then what
i end up with is a higher order saddle
point here and so here i would say k
equals to three
and so
the main result is that um
a few examples so for tensor pca the
information exponent is uh exactly the
order of the tensor so as soon as you
get beyond two this flatness is really
severe essentially
um in the one layer gaussian
network the one layer network with
gaussian features it depends on the
hermit coefficient of the activation
function and in the binary mixture model
it's a k equals to two kind of problems
so you have some saddle but it's a mild
one
so the main result is this kind of
classification of the time scales on
which it takes to escape this saddle
point for the stochastic gradient
descent
okay so
what you have is there's this uh let's
say alpha critical is this this is the
sample complexity so the ratio of m over
n that you really need to escape
and when k equals to one you just linear
time is enough as i said
um because there's no like slow down at
the initialization when k equals to two
it's logarithmic
which you maybe guessed from like a
matrix pca kind of intuition it takes n
log n time to get to the true
eigenvector
and when k is at least three you have
this polynomial slow downwards so k is
at least three this becomes polynomially
large okay and this corresponds to the
kinds of thresholds that you have in
terms of needing polynomially diverging
signal to noise in like a tensor pca
problem
okay and so our main result is that if
you take at least this much data
then the stochastic gradient descent
with a good well-tuned step size goes to
one its correlation goes to one
and uh
essentially this many steps up to like a
log or two is necessary for the online
stochastic gradient descent also okay so
without that many steps it's really the
instability is going to prevent it from
leaving
um and so here's a
little simulation of a couple of like
the hermit first hermit coefficient
second hermit coefficient and third
hermit coefficient used as activation
functions in your single layer model and
you see that the time scales to recovery
are completely
different they match what we expect
and i'll just end quickly with two
warnings in terms of the initialization
in terms of why things are even more
subtle than just what i explained so for
instance what i was saying was you
initialize with a one on root n
correlation which is the typical start
so what if you started with something
that's uh sorry this should be n to the
minus zeta so something that's
microscopically close to the origin but
on a different order of magnitude so
whereas for uh
for the simpler k equals to one and k
equals to two settings that doesn't make
much difference when k is at least three
this can change the polynomial in terms
of how long it takes okay
and what that means is if i start say on
the other side so with half probability
i end i start at minus
one over square root n the correlation
instead of one over square root n
correlation right a random
initialization isn't gonna pick a sign
typically
then it can actually take a much longer
amount of time in this uh in this k at
least three regime because you first
have to wait until you cross the
the
y-axis and for that you're basically
just doing a random walk so you need to
leverage the noise in your sgd and there
things uh
slow down and then you get to the other
side so in these kinds of problems it
could be that a random initialization
half the time gives you one time scale
to recovery and half the time gives you
a completely different time scale to
recovery and
i expect that in higher
kind of higher dimensional problems
where the phi depends on more variables
it could be that you have a whole host
of different time scales depending on
like the number of saddles you have to
pass through so i think there's a lot to
explore in terms of these kinds of
near-saddle behaviors where the
population dynamics itself is slowed
down and the sgd itself should also be
slowed down as a result so i'll stop
there
[Applause]
so this is
extremely minor like nitpicking question
but in the in your main theorem
when uh in the k at least three
regime is there some
like are there kind of log terms hidden
so that log that shows up when k is two
is it still there but just kind of not
making an important contribution or does
it really switch to being truly this
polynomial no so it should be truly a
it's like actually going to be a very
sharp like number basically which is
given to you by the initialization
because once you have like so the log is
coming from a grand wall type of thing
where you have to like you're getting
some like exponential growth because
it's a
and then the in the k at least three
case it's like a higher order
non-linearity so there's a very sharp
time at which you recover depending on
the value of the initialization
so i mean like small small oscillations
in the initialization make big changes
in the time scale but if i fix an
initialization it'll be a very sharp
time
yeah i'm just also curious about i guess
this is when the the likelihood or
whatever is not
one dimensional
but uh do you have are there analogous
results about escaping from saddle
points but we're only a handful
you're in a high dimensional setting and
only they're only a small number of
unstable directions
yeah so it's i think that's an
interesting question that i mean we're
kind of trying to look into is
so the the key thing here is that it's
like a kind of escaping saddles with
noise but the initial data point the
initialization is also like
dimension dependently close to the
saddle itself and so that trade off in a
like let's say a system where you have a
cascade of 10 saddles would be an
interesting question to understand and
relevant to like low dimension to other
low dimensional but not one-dimensional
problems so you might have a few
directions that lead to a few saddles
and depending on which trajectory you
take you can get different time scales
to recover if there are tons of papers
on this single topic escaping
but in high dimensions
michael jordan
and the other remark is that every
single problem that you treated there
are sharper results available in the
literature yeah so i would say like
we're not aiming to get sharp results in
terms of like
just algorithmic thresholds or things
like that and a lot of people have
worked on these kinds of things for
specific problems for tons of things i
think the goal is really to understand
like
what are the specifics of the escape
from the saddle point in this regime
where both your initialization is going
close to the saddle and also your
dimension is diverging
great okay in the interest of time i
think we should uh thank reza again and
move on
[Applause]
um so